talleyrand forme jeff dont 12 ont beige
est en train de m'allumer à mort au
voulez parler de mon vagin
cette femme est une plaie awards je
regardais c'est la mer bizarre qui sort
pas de chez elle mais qu'est ce que
cette bille et les filles
mathieu a passé la nuit à vomir dessus
tout va bien même si j'ai pas beaucoup
dormi quel malheur sa tristesse va
déteindre sur moi et voici amy tu
arrives à abandonner ses enfants pour
aller travailler c'est dur mais j'ai
aussi besoin de choses comme un peu de
pognon et oui à tout à l'heure dans elle
travaille tellement ça mais pas sa fille
travaille tellement oui c'est ce que je
viens de dire chez qui j'ai quatre
minutes pour déposer aux cochers lever
tôt
ça devrait aller c'est grave à la peau
pour la réunion marketing je ne crois
pas je vais être en retard à mon premier
entraînement de foot de l'année c'est
une mauvaise journée y peut rien
m'arriver pire
merde j'ai organisé cette réunion
d'extrême urgence pour éradiquer
définitivement ce fléau qui affecte la
santé de nos enfants
le terrorisme la fente de gâteaux
persiennes blague
qu'est ce que j'entends je suis désolé
j'en ai marre
à notre époque c'est impossible d'être
une mère parfaite
soyons des mères indignes ça me branche
aux mères avaient vécu son va tout et me
salue j'appelais pour savoir si tu
voulais faire un ciné avec moi
aujourd'hui
pourquoi on a le droit de faire ça c'est
littéralement la meilleure journée de la
vie depuis que je suis né mais à mots à
lui mis on a une petite réunion parents
d'élèves antilles vers un nom bail
je dirige cette école alors personne ne
va en classe où se mettent à jouer de la
clarinette sens que je donne mon accord
cette fille est un despote il faut qu'on
dégage les mères parfaites
il dit qu'il faut pour frappe cette
bataille en plein dans les nibards c'est
la meilleure réunion parents d'élèves
koné qu'un seul pénis depuis que je suis
sur le marché et si je tombe sur
quelqu'un qui est pas circoncis je vais
te montrer la cl bout du pénis tu vois
tu mets le tout en arrière et tu fais un
aller retour
mais qu'est ce que je fais de faire du
tout que c'est un immense plateau
masculin tac asus et tu bois tu colles
ta bouche en pleine suez après elle
devait plus jamais porter ce gilet les
filles [ __ ] tu m'as piqué à ta mère ça
c'est mon soutif y perd 6,6 un mono ni
les pare balles c'est carrément par bit
ces six mois je samui bien c'est très
confortable
je vais essayer de me débrouiller tout
seul aujourd'hui
du moment que tout le monde fait ce
qu'il est censé faire c'est compris j'ai
déposé ce que j'ai fait ou alors je vous
aime et dégager le trésor l'union par
ambroise a prévu un urgente à 17 heures
je vais te vas trouver une baby sitter
un soir de semaine à leur excellente
idée
je ne crois pas être en retard à mon
premier entraînement de foot de l'année
désolé je fais ce que je suis matt est
un peu plus d'efforts mais retenir mais
la vente de gâteaux pas de msg pas de bh
année de bep acheter ni noisette mieux
il est ni beurre ni celle du grenoble et
j'en ai plus qu'assez d'essayer d'être
la mère parfaite
j'en ai marre du bâti tout on trouve que
j'ai toujours ressenti santé lire sur le
rôle de mère au drug c'est chiant
impunis patinant dit pas non à des taux
record
alors si vous en avez juste ras le bol
de ces mamans soi-disant parfaite ils
vous disent que vos gâteaux ne sont pas
assez bons pour la kermesse de l'école
vous vous êtes dit une maman qui veut en
faire un peu moins
alors stop soyons des blindés je vais
vous détruire
c'est ce type de ta mère en france et
mon soutif hyper sexy on dirait un hyper
lent ni chance et un mot nos nichons
[ __ ] je les aime tellement je pourrais
mourir à la seconde pour eux petit
[ __ ] à l'université j'habite je suis
allée comme les enfants sont un cadeau